[Music]
and everybody welcome back to another
awesome episode of the careful boys
where we like to keep it extremely
careful very careful super careful maybe
not but
we have a very very uh fun and serious
question at the same time that we want
to discuss this came up in a car ride
yesterday and we felt like sharing the
depth
of
would you guys i know bart's in a
different category why what was this
about
finish are we doing western rules or
eastern eastern okay international would
you like to have children if so how many
and why yeah bart would you like to have
children yeah bart you're gonna have
kids now that i have one i made a big
mistake
wrong wife huh yeah yeah yeah
no ideally
thanks for sharing i think ideally um
probably two so we are trying this year
but i think just having like you know
like having someone that they could play
with what inspired you for the second
but didn't you guys say you were done
why did you lie why did you lie why did
you change your mind you [ __ ] played
with our hearts on youtube you lied to
your audience who lied to us you lied to
your family
i'm still stuck on your first forever
just shows a lot of character i guess
well i think that i built a career off
the line so i just want to continue that
just keep it going what inspired the
second um i think we've always wanted to
we just didn't know so like the big like
thing is uh you know you're always
trying to like
this is how i felt like our childhood
was these are some of the things that
our parents could have done better so
when you're a parent like you're always
trying to go like okay how can we make
it better than the last generation right
so i think for us from the get we're
like we want to have to
but the minute that we had one and we
realized raising that one is already
twice the effort than the way our
parents had them
then we're like oh [ __ ] with our
schedule and just how busy things are
like if we have two it almost feels like
it would dilute the attention of the one
because of the way we want to raise them
in 2022 you know because i think back in
the day it was cool to just have kids
and then like uh where's the
grandparents at there you are see you
later i'll see you [ __ ] that sounds
wonderful still people could still do
that by the way hell would do that but i
think uh yeah like in this generation
people are really trying to like be
nurturing be there for them so i think
when we had one in reality hit we're
like it's gonna dilute attention away
from taika he's super cool
um but just kind of like as geo's about
to hit that expiration date
she's geriatric yeah we're like yo it's
a wall bro
we're like i found out that a geriatric
pregnancy is actually after 33 or
something like that
was geriatric pregnancy then yeah but
we're like but to further joe's point
geo is geriatric yes
so we're like we've seen like swiss
cheese turned into like provolone and
it's about to be blue cheese oh wow what
are we gonna do what are we gonna do the
next thing you just throw it away yeah i
know so we just did last year
this is the the like the day old bread
phase of it it's getting hard it's
getting hard it's getting real rock hard
and then you can't really sell it
tomorrow so i think this year we're like
if it happens
awesome it was in the cards if not it's
still totally cool because that's true
taika is really cool that's tight that's
cool man what if he wasn't really cool
yeah dude honestly what if the second
one comes out and you're just like [ __ ]
damn roe v wade just [ __ ] got
overturned
i don't know if that'll fly after they
come out
is that how it works i mean [ __ ]
boy or girl
uh it doesn't really matter
if you had to boy for sure what another
boy if i had if i was like if i could
choose then i would be a boy because
taika is such a like like boy type
character i think having a buddy that
was on the same wavelength you want an
exact same isn't that kind of like his
cousins already though you know what i
mean like you wouldn't want and that's
why i think that would be that would be
cool because he only gets that when
we're here
and when we're back in vegas i'm like
man he's missing that kind of energy
there's no like
boyish voice in vegas nope boys boys
like his friends yeah like whatever you
say like like we're talking about like
he he only gets that with his cousins oh
i mean like at home in the home
environment like
jiu-jitsu yeah he's like boy and girl
they're all like having a good time
school having a good time but like in
the home environment he doesn't have the
like
you know like boy camaraderie yeah like
[ __ ] just wrestle in the room for no
reason yeah and [ __ ] smash your legos
and you smash my rc car
is it doesn't
yeah i so i'm right now i'm probably
like his buddy um but then you get tired
sometimes you know so you're like it'd
be cool if you're able to go here like i
go to jill's brother's house and i go in
because he got four kids and i'm
expecting [ __ ] he has a fake titty
out to like breastfeed and he has to do
this he's washing dishes i go in and
this was just there like
watching like old school military
documentaries and [ __ ] and i'm like
what the [ __ ] and i heard that's the
good thing about having multiple kids
they just take care of each other
and then like you see like these two
kids fighting already right and they're
like both four the older sister who's
like only eight already knows how to
sort the problem like she's on her ipad
and the two kids are like okay cool and
they just run off
you know like it has so much more chain
of command before requires appearance
plus i think you're a good example of
this only children are pretty weird
that's very true
yeah i'm weird as [ __ ] it's because only
childs get they don't have to compromise
for [ __ ] they get everything they want a
lot of attention they got all the
attention they know how to [ __ ] share
i feel like they're late all the time as
well
so my other friends who are only childs
i'm like oh i don't want to hang out
with you anymore dude sound of a [ __ ]
yeah you guys are ruining it
are you going to do kids joe oh hell
yeah oh duo i would have already
dead to rights
you're going down you son of a [ __ ]
to me it's always been a money thing
right if i had mad [ __ ] money like a
trust fund kid or whatever and i was
just never worried for the rest of my
life
[ __ ] dude i would have already had like
10 kids
that i did that's where you would spend
your money on
no i just feel like i don't want to be
a deadbeat dad in that way so he wants
to be able to afford child care so when
he leaves the ladies yeah i want to be
present you just want him to be provided
i'm a 1950s dad
so like uh i i'll i'll pay for i want i
want to take care of my son yeah take
care of my son your kid has a flu you
like you give him a cigarette
you'll be fine
not enough doctors it is my zama lose
three anyway
yeah i think that would be pretty cool
um
but
the logical side the reasonable side
comes in and they're like i just see
like bar and like all my friends with
like kids and [ __ ] i'm like [ __ ]
dude that is that is just a lot of like
personal sacrifice that i'm not ready to
give just yet
but thank god hannah's not geriatric yet
we got a couple of years yeah still in
the swiss cheese face she switched blue
cheese yet so uh i might create and and
and do cream pies but we'll have to take
uh uh year by year we have to see we're
still growing this relationship it's
still new you know but if i did have the
money though probably been [ __ ]
busting nuts first week without birth
control easily yeah multiple children
with [ __ ] baby mama suing me that
that's that would have been my life i'm
glad you're still doing cream pies
though that's good i know it was either
either children or cream pies you know
what i mean maybe i'm just not a potent
human being because i [ __ ] did a lot
of cream pies yeah i got very lucky you
shouldn't just be a baker
i'm a cream pie doughnut kind of guy but
oh god very anytime you bring donuts to
them joe's house is called winchell's
open 24 7 baby i do love you but real
talk though i do want kids like i
[ __ ] love the energy of uh
i just like people right and then that
that they're small even better even
better cause you can just pick them up
and [ __ ] toss them and throw them and
kick them or whatever you like small
people oh but
we all we all do you like punting
children just having the energy of a lot
of uh
just human beings in the house it makes
it lively yeah and i always grew up with
that like i had a in my family it was my
mom my dad my grandma my brother me and
it will always have guests or family
members over
and then at one time we had uh my my um
my aunt and her family in one [ __ ]
house and that was one of the funnest
memories i've had and i think that
energy is just so much more different
than an empty house of just like some
people who are introverts love that [ __ ]
but for me i like chaos it's just wake
up chaotic
this is always just never boring you
know there's a lot of stimulation
and um yeah and then also like
right now might be a burden but i think
about the future future where i'm a
grandparent and then the holidays are
around and then you just see your legacy
you just see all these people just
fighting in the over the dinner table
and you're laughing yes and you're just
like this is what i made
that's why i could see you being an
uncle yeah i could see you being uncle
jeff like you're you're uncle joe so you
would just show up for the for the
christmas and be like everyone's
here's some here kids hear some [ __ ]
firecrackers have fun watch this from
the side
it is harder this generation i feel like
compared to last because
in the last one it's like the the the
sentiment is the minute you have kids
you give up your life or your passion
and it's all about them right like i
definitely felt that from my parents
like the minute they had me like it was
their focus was on me but i think in
this generation where there's a lot
about what's your identity and like what
what your passions are and people they
go
uh i gotta find myself in [ __ ]
whatever right finding yourself it's not
even a concept before yeah they're all
thinking survival yeah that's all
there's there's nothing else yeah so now
if the minute you have a kid you're like
oh [ __ ] i gotta i
now you gotta split your your pursuit in
two channels so my friends that are my
age uh that say they don't want kids i'm
like i totally get it too because if
you're not done pursuing what you want
to pursue
the minute you have a kid it's going to
like put the brakes on it i kind of like
that too because i kind of like that
people are also not feeling like they
have to have kids it's like a box to
check yeah it's like a thing where they
have to like oh well i just gotta have a
family now that's what i have yeah even
though i'm an alcoholic guy guys i have
to do this
i think it'll i think it'll fix the
marriage if we ever get yeah you know
like that [ __ ] oh my god we know people
like that that usually works yeah yeah
so i'm just like
it's kind of better because now i feel
like a lot a lot more kids won't have to
like exist in that space which is like
what raised a lot of very interesting
but maybe a little [ __ ] up people that
we currently know so i have a question
for joe specifically
if you guys have kids are you going to
raise them british are you going to
raise them american goddamn america so
we talked about geographically and
culturally too yeah what kind of accent
are they going to have so
healthcare in the uk is free
and um their [ __ ] birthing program
all that [ __ ] is pretty sick because out
here since it's a business they just try
to crank out babies
and so they encourage c-sections way
better you know all that out there it's
completely free and they take as much
time as they need to do the process
good we're like that when the baby pops
out the mama gets to [ __ ] hold the
baby all this [ __ ] and
then like they don't just rush you out
of the hospital yeah so it's a different
vibe and i was like but if you do
[ __ ] all of this like you know
socialized care isn't it like cheaper
quality and she goes no it's like the
school system here in the u.s right so
some neighborhoods are rich so the
school system even though it's public
it's sick and in some places are poor so
the hospitals or it's the same concept
out there so you you're in a good
neighborhood you have a good hospital
and i was like all right and then the
other thing is she has a huge [ __ ]
family huge right and then so
she has three uh brothers and on top of
that hella cousins hella aunts all that
and they're all down to help
um for me i have a geriatric ass mom
[ __ ]
practically a fossil at this point she
lives in japan right i have some family
members here in america but i don't know
how i'm gonna do that yeah so for the
first one we're like uh uk is probably
the the the place to be but we'll see
after that and see like all the the
possibilities of like [ __ ] maybe
doing it in every state so we have a kid
with a different accent every time but
think about the downside of that because
yeah your kid having a [ __ ] accent
you can barely even understand what
they're saying that could be really bad
especially because they're northerners
so they don't even speak like [ __ ]
london british harry potter peoples i'm
just like what the [ __ ] are you saying
you peaky blinder [ __ ] they're like pop
i'm absolutely gutted
burning them yeah falling out of this
spot
you're gonna teach your children white
privilege because they're gonna be lucky
i'm gonna hate my colonial as [ __ ]
halfers dude
you know what japanese were colonists
too so i guess [ __ ] it's kind of
romantic right yeah that's true it's a
little poetic yeah i guess so you should
just name your kid colony or something
call me
colin
colonial just to make it clear colonizer
what are you nick we talked about it we
we're you guys been married for a long
time you i think your relationship is
the longest one here huh now that you
guys probably have well we've been
together for like 12 years
but a lot of the a lot of the first
beginning of our relationship was like
you know we were still like young adults
we were [ __ ] babies ourselves too you
know so
you know we're thinking about
maybe in a couple years trying
but i think tiff really wants to have a
baby how many
you like one or two probably two maybe
like but you just never know how [ __ ]
life you know shakes out you never know
just say dude what do you want man yeah
i want kids i think everybody's
like two i think two would be good yeah
two would be solid
yeah it seems manageable in my head but
then again i've never [ __ ] had a kid
so what the [ __ ] do i know that life's
crazy like yeah jill's brother they were
trying to have kids for i think like
eight years old right nothing and then
they're like [ __ ] man ate your cream pie
yeah and then
and then boom boom boom yeah so like the
boy came the girl came and then twins
and he's like holy [ __ ] it's like trying
to get the saucer machine if it doesn't
work
you're at the vending machine and you're
trying to like knock out your just like
you're like stuck like snack and then it
like falls over before you break the
glass oh god because they're about to
accept it they're like i guess it's not
for us yeah and then it was like it's
funny how that works right that's what
was playing jenga with his [ __ ]
birthing process man once again ryan
with the rich people problems though
he's like yeah and what are we gonna do
with all these snacks for free like give
them to the homeless steve
i help uh boy or girlfriends if you had
to choose i honestly don't really care
um tiff has more of a preference but
what about even about one percent even
about what point one percent though you
know
in my head in my head a boy has its own
particular issues and then having a girl
has his own particularly obviously which
set of issues do you want to deal with
though nick's deflecting again
i thought you opened up what happened
really i really don't know let's pull up
some better ones complaining one's gonna
break [ __ ] yeah exactly like to me it's
like [ __ ] it's right down the path
you know it's like it's it's they're
both gonna be pains in the asses of
their own ways um so it's like it's like
a split it's like it's it's it cancels
each other out but typically i don't
want girls right but i think they're
very useful so the first one i would say
girl
because they're gonna take the burden
off of you for being the third parent i
think so first one's the girl i've seen
that happen yeah rest of them
girl boy girl don't [ __ ] matter dude
i think girl's a piece of [ __ ] it's just
super selfish then you [ __ ] up as a
parent right you did then you [ __ ] up
i've never seen it when a girl doesn't
[ __ ] kick into gear and treat her
siblings as barbie dolls yeah for real
for real it happens that's what happened
to my sister so if wants a boy yeah i
don't care i just i would like to have a
balance i would like to have one of each
in a perfect world but i don't care
which one comes out first what if what
if his boy comes out first boy wants to
be a fighter what are you gonna say
you're like you better pick something
else dude why
you better pick something else or if we
do it if my kid wants to be a fighter we
gotta do it the [ __ ] right way like
we're gonna be doing like we're starting
at like four years old and we're like
we're gonna make this kid [ __ ] legit
at the same time yeah we gotta go to
dagestan bro i'm gonna get the [ __ ]
chin strap beard and everything i'm
speaking russian so you're not gonna
push him into fighting you know nah bro
like i thought i'd push him but he's
gonna have nothing but fight posters all
over the wall he's gonna have all his
fight friends come over all the time
like both of my kids no matter what both
of my kids are gonna do some sort of
martial art they're gonna be wrestling
they're gonna be doing jiu jitsu like
they have to be competent in that like
that's a pre-wreck no matter what boy or
girl don't matter they have to have
those skills already i don't care if
they read but like they have to learn
how to grapple and protect themselves
yeah but they can beat up nerds who can
read exactly and that's when it works
out dude because i can't help them with
reading that's when tiff comes in oh
you're honorary you gotta punch in the
head too many times i was on hooked on
phonics when i was in second grade you
know i looked on back shots some other
jeans are really strong man like i think
like taika just has like this bunny jean
because uh like now he understands
timing and stuff like at night well me
and jill put him to bed every single
abc's whatever and then we turn off the
lights and then at the right before we
leave his room he goes hey we're like
what he goes
good night barton geo
a little fun oh my god who is this
sitcom who's writing the sitcom he's a
sitcom kid i'm like what the [ __ ] did
this guy crazy
i'm like what
he's a nut what about you anthony lee
you're over here asking all these
goddamn questions you're the provocateur
here
that's all kinds of [ __ ] yeah
i would love to have children i would i
would uh i would be so blessed because i
i do have friends that like have been
trying and stuff like that maybe haven't
seen that type of success yet um love to
uh to be completely honest i would love
to quite soon um
within the next three years soon yeah
yeah for sure within the next three
years totally because i'm geriatric you
know what i'm saying you're not
geriatrics i've been having kids 33 i'm
you know jerry actually guys can be like
70. 65 technically but as long as
yeah
as long as we're all men yeah
i would love to have
at least two kids as well um i i grew up
with only one older sister so i only
know a two kid in the family situation
um i agree because i had an older sister
i feel like uh
i would want a a daughter first if i had
to if i had the choice yeah uh in in the
same way i think that a girl would be
older brother just [ __ ] with you
non-stop that's very true yeah you're
just the entertainment i would not mind
uh a boy first i think even the idea
of a uh you know a bigger brother to to
watch over a younger because i would die
if i had like a [ __ ] dog that would
be like the illest i think i think god
would be like anthony you deserve a
daughter for all your [ __ ] stupid
thoughts um so i deserve it true but i
think yeah but i think i would love sex
havers curse love to have a daughter
and be like you know have that daddy's
girl kind of like relationship um but it
doesn't really matter what order as long
as it happens i also think that because
i only had a sister i like ended up like
subconsciously creating all guy crew
dance team and like found found brothers
like as like surrogate family members
so the idea of having multiple like boys
in the household or something like that
is also [ __ ] exciting to me but i
have no idea what that's like all boys
is nuts though it gets old
you know what my ideal scenario is
honestly
uh do you follow mma a little bit or no
just a little bit are you familiar with
the diaz brothers
i'm familiar with nate diaz but i would
love to have a set of diaz brothers
those fools are obnoxious but if you
[ __ ] with any one of them they got each
other's backs like like there's this
reporter that asked so uh at the time
when nate didn't have as many losses
they're interviewing like nick like um
like if you guys were to fight like who
would win and i think he slapped the mic
out of that guy's hand why would you ask
a stupid [ __ ] question like that yeah
and i'm like i would ask that question
that's a good question yeah but the
reporter got [ __ ] scared i'm like
that's that true brother love right
there that's that's like that insecure
weird [ __ ] i was like that sounds like
mental illness there i like that kind of
mental thing how about you
oh yeah we won't have kids for sure but
but we go back and forth so often we
just moved to vegas it's like paradise
like i feel like we live in a resort now
so it's like
god do we want to fill this house with
the screaming baby so it's like vacation
mode mine instead of like family mode
mine or you could enjoy it for a few
more years i mean yeah we'll we'll see
because it's getting to that point like
geriatric prediction [ __ ] where it's
like man we don't want to she's not blue
cheese though we don't want to temp fate
no i mean she's not like though the
bread you can't even give the homeless
people yet like jio
you know but you know that day will come
yeah but you can't have a kid get in the
way of a poker career no exactly there's
so much cool [ __ ] going on she's just
getting just getting going dude how
[ __ ] gangster that be though she's
[ __ ] breastfeeding at the table and
just [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] ball
insane like it could be even part of her
like strategy no he's putting chips on
her belly
knowing
stupid knowing my nicki though she will
go all in on motherhood good but but
she'll give up on what she's really
enjoying and i wouldn't want that yeah
yeah so it's a shame she's not more like
neglecting you know no she's a psycho
bro when she go when she goes in on
something she goes like all the [ __ ]
way in jackhammers it so
i don't know well it's going to take
some time because we're still really
enjoying the [ __ ] right now so that's
awesome yeah
we'll get there
or we'll adopt or freeze our eggs or
whatever no pressure
or pressure either i don't care i mean
we honestly we joke about this all the
time but we kind of just want to have a
kid just to see what our baby would look
like and then have somebody else raise
it for a couple years and then pick it
up when it's like cool like when tyka
got fun tekka was so [ __ ] boring at
first that's one of our strategies yeah
and then but with the picking tuck up
when he's like four years old and five
years old having fun yeah just with no
connection to you at all just the first
two years he's got just kind of wet dude
yeah first two years like this just the
[ __ ] dumb worm that you're crying
has a sense of humor you know
with me it's way better all my nieces
and nephews is the same [ __ ] it's like
they're so [ __ ] boring and then now
they're really fun you're just sitting
there and there's [ __ ] this drill
coming out like what the [ __ ] dude even
day one so like you know my first niece
was born and we go there it's like wow
this is crazy and then it's like
[Laughter]
do a trick or anything
just laying in a blanket rather have a
cat
did ryan answer no
answer oh i don't want kids right now
there it is
credits credits
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you